October 2009 was the worst month
of the worst year of the Great Recession.
One out of every ten Americans
was out of work.
It was bad.
But not as bad as the worst year
of the Great Depression,
when the unemployment rate
was one in four.
Few Americans alive today have ever seen that
many people out of work.
Until now.
"Coronavirus outbreaks at meatpacking plants,
forcing many to close."
"Ford, General Motors, and Fiat Chrysler,
all temporarily closing US plants
because of the coronavirus."
"Parking lots, bare.
Retail stores, corporate offices,
all closed."
By the end of April 2020, 30 million Americans
had filed unemployment claims.
Economists estimated that the
US unemployment rate was about 13%.
The highest since the Great Depression.
But in some other countries,
like the UK, for instance, it’s a totally
different story.
Factories, restaurants,
all that stuff is closed.
But this?
This isn’t happening.
In the US, lawmakers have assumed that
all those closed factories, shops, and restaurants
have one inevitable outcome:
mass unemployment.
But what if that’s wrong?
What if millions of people didn’t have to
lose their jobs?
What if it didn’t have to be this way?
For most of US history, if you were laid off,
you didn’t have a lot of options.
Churches and charities did what they could,
but for the most part, you were on your own.
That changed during the Great Depression.
With help from the federal government,
states began to hold back a share
of every worker’s paycheck.
That money went into a fund that workers
could tap into if they got laid off.
"Workers in every state in the union are now protected if they are temporarily laid off or lose their jobs."
The system worked pretty well, as long as too many people didn’t lose their job all at once.
But that is definitely not what happened during
the coronavirus lockdowns.
You can think of the economy as a web of connections.
During normal times, every day, billions of
dollars change hands across those connections,
between different companies and industries.
Airlines pay oil companies for jet fuel.
Those oil companies pay computer engineers
to make software that helps them
find new reserves.
And those software companies pay ad agencies
to make commercials for them.
Then they pay to put those ads in front of
things you like to watch.
And a tiny portion of that money helps pay
for us to make videos.
We spend some of that money on, say, plane
tickets for reporting trips,
and the whole cycle repeats.
During normal times, these connections are
what allow businesses to pay their employees.
If some connections break,
and a business lays off workers,
unemployment insurance is there
to help them get by,
until those connections re-form,
and businesses are ready to hire again.
But when the lockdowns started,
and businesses closed down,
lots of those connections broke away entirely.
Businesses laid off millions of workers
in just a few weeks,
faster than at any time in US history.
In response, Congress
has passed several bills,
aimed at helping states get unemployment benefits
to more people, more quickly.
But even if that helps in the short term,
it might not be enough down the road.
Because once the lockdowns are over,
many of those businesses
simply won’t be there anymore.
Even if they lay off employees,
businesses still have to pay rent.
Plus insurance, utilities,
and other business costs.
But there’s no money coming in.
Once the lockdown is lifted,
and it’s safe to work again,
a lot of businesses will be gone.
And there will be way fewer jobs
to come back to.
Lots of unemployed people
will likely stay unemployed.
Which will draw the economic crisis
out even further.
But things don’t have to turn out that way.
Just like the US, most of the UK is on lockdown.
Many of those connections
between businesses have fallen off.
But instead of waiting for workers to get laid off,
the UK is doing something different.
The way that they are going about it,
is saying to companies:
“We will pay you
to pay your employees."
Workers get paid 80% of their previous salary,
and businesses get help
covering rent and other costs.
Denmark and the Netherlands have
put similar systems in place.
In all of these countries, government support has
put the economy on pause,
to keep it from falling apart later.
In the US, Congress did set aside a chunk
of money for grants and loans to small businesses,
in the hopes that they would
keep their workers on payroll.
But to get the money, business owners had to apply
through commercial banks,
like Chase and Bank of America.
That extra step, combined with the onslaught
of applications, resulted in massive delays.
By the time many small businesses got approval,
the fund was already empty.
When the US first set up unemployment insurance
during the Great Depression,
that idea didn’t come out of thin air.
Policymakers studied similar systems in England
and Germany, and then adapted them.
This pandemic transcends national borders.
The solutions should too.